all right um well
uh joe rogan stirred up a little a
little controversy so let's let's just
play it
and let's figure out who he's talking
about what do you say
pre-kingdom yeah you become someone
who is on stimulants all the time and i
know
several people that have an issue i know
one guy's completely lost his mind
thinks everybody's against him
thinks that uh everyone's done him wrong
and he's just out there
cracked out in the middle of nowhere on
adderall every day
and making youtube videos and there's a
lot of people like that man
who do you think he's talking about
who who do you who could joe rogan be
talking
i have no idea i'm no no point of
reference here
there's a lot of people like that it is
a meth-like drug
it's very very very very similar to meth
yeah it's just a different release in
terms of like that how quickly your body
processes crazy how well now before we
move on to the adderall stuff and look
joe rogan let's get his criticized
whatever he wants but let's not talk
about
mr you still does but used to do a lot
of steroids rogan telling people what
what to put in their body
you know what i mean yeah and he's still
doing it no he's i think but he's
smaller than he used to be trt
he's trt rogan now old school when rogan
still was fighting off the hair
that was deca d-ball testosterone rogan
that was a
joe rogan uh two days ago on his podcast
without referring to me by name because
he can't
uh for some reason why would he because
he doesn't want to give you attention
because he knows
what you want literally the biggest
youtuber in the world yeah that's like
why would he tell you anything that's
what
that's what he wants but look here's the
thing look we we make fun of owen a lot
right
a lot a lot but you know he's a comic
so rogan went in on him hard right he's
messed out you know sitting there
screaming he's not gonna take this [ __ ]
no he's gonna he's gonna hit back hard
he's a big
you know what they say about owen
benjamin he's a counter puncher on his
podcast without referring to me by name
because he can't
uh for some reason said that i'm a speed
freak in the woods uh and i don't have
any friends
well i don't even drink beer let alone
do speed
and if i ever did speed i would stare
blankly and not
say anything so um
he's a sodomite who looks like a human
toe oh
[ __ ] look i don't really like rogan i
have a lot of problems with rogan to be
honest with you
but he broke you down
to your core like that's what he did
also you
just tried to rebut several points that
joe rogan did never made
he never said you were drinking he never
said he was doing speed either he said
you were doing adorable and he didn't
say you have no friends
you said that so
where my dream is to
is to educate the nation of america
to such a degree about what to rogan is
and what he brings
that they do not allow him in idaho
because he's going to leave la soon he
knows it's fallen
based on what he uh he pushes
now of course guilty conscience owen
always outs himself too um and you know
we haven't checked in on him you sent me
this guilty conscience owen he was on
that song
yeah he was him and dre and eminem yeah
they cut it for the radio version
but if you listen to the extended track
on the remastered chronic 2001
oh no it was uh slim shady lp excuse me
i apologize it's very easy to make that
yeah uh owen benjamin has gone full
brendan dilly
oh this one's great all right so let's
check i mean we haven't checked in on
this boy in a while so
let's see what he's doing
before we continue didn't he admit to
like snorting lines of what was
ritalin okay you can't [ __ ] the tuck i'm
a voice of the people
let me know if you think this is a shout
out from old tuck
peck peck peck pecks
so check out tucker carlson and then
we'll uh
we'll go from there okay watch the tuck
the left is now telling you and
demanding that you believe
that anyone who supports donald trump is
a white
and if you're allowed to think about
that for long enough you might start to
get
unauthorized ideas about economics
he thinks i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i haven't seen this yet
i'm sorry holy [ __ ] he thinks because
tucker used the word
unauthorized tucker is plugging
um unauthorized dude as best he can i
mean he can't just blatantly say it on
fox he'd lose his job
so he's got to be a little less on the
nose about it
it's clear as day he said it we both
heard it so if you're gonna sit there
and pretend like
owen's just making these fantastic
delusions up in his head then
and if you were allowed to think about
that for long enough you might start to
get unauthorized ideas about economics
ah of all the words he could have used
listen hi tucker
that again watch one more time
you might start to get unauthorized
ideas about economics
and that would be disruptive to a very
lucrative status quo
so they whip you into a frenzy of racial
fear so that it never enters your mind
people have used the word unauthorized
before i think he's
they i'm sorry i know you're saying it
in a funny voice but if you don't mind
they have on a regular basis it was a
word it was a word
before it was your dumb thing it was a
word
watches trump does as well a lot of them
do
no yeah true no no trump and tucker i'll
watch
no no no
no thanks owen very cool
your mind people have used the word
unauthorized before
i think he's watches uh trump does as
well a lot of them do
but the unauthorized is definitely a
shout out hey make sure the wi-fi is
back up on air force when i gotta catch
me the owen benjamin
have you seen him lately he does he
calls them small hats
it's very funny this is great baron come
in here let me show you a real man
i want you to grow up to be just like
him
he thinks the president of the united
states watches him scream in the yard
he doesn't even know how to use obs
correctly he doesn't even attend all his
meetings
he doesn't even have advisors anymore
because he hates the job so much you
think he's watching your streams
and then i've heard trump say hey i'm
gonna grab a dad coke and just go
upstairs and lay down for a little bit
it's been a tough one today it's been
real too
trump has a feed the bear subscription
mark i said yeah i'm sure he does
guys is definitely a shout out and then
i've heard his box do you accept black
card
trump say uh this guy gets it
no one's ever said this guy gets it
before owen benjamin did
he's lost his mind
he's really lost rogan may be on to
something people love them someone run
out their wife before
oh yeah you're crazy
[Music]
you you are oh someone's right there is
somebody in this chairman called potus
bear
so that must be your case closed
let's picture trump is the avatar it
must be yeah it's him
no i'm just i'm typically when people
call me crazy it's because i'm smarter
than them i understand
am i the only one who's just
uncomfortable and sad now for him
like this used to be fun owen no it's
still fun for me people that call me
they they call me crazy is because
you're smarter than them
you know who says that crazy people
i spent i sent you down a crowder's
spiral
live within minutes
you're not that smart understand that
i didn't i didn't even use a burner
email or anything no you sent it from
yours he said it from merch comedy
gmail hey owen here's crowder and he
spiraled for
days about it weeks he still mentions it
smart guy land the plane
do you say land the plane there was
another one that was just mind-blowing
whatever man if you wanted to grade
yourself like that go ahead
that unauthorized is legit
uh that's legit owen is so desperate for
acceptance it's sad says guy who just
got banned
uh can you play it again nice work yes
i i really like tr uh tucker carlson and
not just because of this i've always
liked him
he's one of the only people in
mainstream media that says anything
that's true ever
and he will turn on tucker within the
month like everybody else in his life
like literally everybody turn on talker
because tucker doesn't want anything to
do with it yeah it's not like tucker
he's not teddy spaghetti yeah crowder
working-class people of all colors
have a lot more in common infinitely
more you know it would be hilarious if
the tucker carlson show hit him with a
copyright strike
how he would lose his mind with each
other
than they do with some overpaid msnbc
anchor and if you're allowed to think
about that for long enough
you might start to get unauthorized
ideas about economics
and that would be disruptive to a very
lucrative status quo it is
so they whip you into it
it is owen doesn't even understand
what's being spoken known as a child
this is a child
owen doesn't even understand what
tucker's talking about
owen is somebody when when smarter
people are talking around him
he goes yeah you're no i totally agree
precisely he says where's like
precisely it's like a child going into a
room with a demolition crew and them
going all right
check it out we're gonna knock down this
wall here and this one don't touch these
two columns because they're load-bearing
and we'll take the whole building down
and uh by the way there's asbestos we're
gonna have to remove it up there and
there's just a six-year-old going
yeah totally yeah we'll do that i know
that i hear that
you're just like that's cute go outside
to a frenzy of racial
fear so that it never enters your mind
yep
you know mike we've said mind before on
this show so tucker is clearly watching
mind control see tucker's watching us
and he's the guy that they're trying to
get to replace tucker it's just another
grabbler little grubbler
that's by the way grabbler again he's
using grabbler that's that's an
onion bit we've played we've actually
played the onion bit
even things that owen says are his
things aren't even his things
it's not that they're not his things
because people these comics all [ __ ]
steal from each other right
but they're so blatantly and glaringly
not his like it's not like he's still
it's not like he went to an open mic
like robin williams and stole some joke
from some [ __ ] middle act at the ice
house
this is [ __ ] it's it's a bit that
blew up
viral again it went because it went it
went re-viral around
and he picked up on it and he thinks
that it's hit like he's nuts
he's a [ __ ] lunatic there you go by
the way
that you used to talk about noah anymore
we just did all right and then now we're
gonna get
is that all you guys do is talk about
owen yes yes we do both
we do both of those things at the same
time that's all i do all i do
is talk about owen and [ __ ] your wife
whoever just said
whoever's going to say that in the
comments all right cool